it's been just disaster after disaster
and then we found this clip from the
televised mental institution known as
msnbc where this woman her name is
michelle singletary she's basically
telling us all to shut up because well
well take a look for yourself where we
are right now
you know
i'm just going to say this and and and
if i get bang for it i don't care there
are there is a great deal of americans
where it is uncomfortable that they're
spending more but they are not going to
go under you know you you got to stop
complaining when there's so many people
who literally the inflation rate means
they may only have two meals instead of
three there are americans who did
extremely well in the last two years in
the market you still have your job and
yeah it's costing you more for gas but
guess what you're still going to take
that holiday that fourth of july
vacation you could still eat out so i'm
gonna need you to calm down and back off
because it feeds into this fear and then
this fear feeds into people making
decisions that creates the very thing
that they're fearful of
if there was ever a clip that perfectly
illustrates why everyone sort of hates
progressives at this point that's sort
of holier than thou
you have to do this if it's not directly
affecting you then you better shut up
and don't talk about our guy who's in
charge right now man it's libby it's the
whole thing related to media and reality
versus what they want to show us right
yeah and she's also saying
don't fight for people who are
struggling more than you which is
supposed to be their whole thing isn't
that their game their whole thing what
happened to you know using your
privilege to fight for people who have
less privilege no apparently not for
this woman so basically everything she's
saying is actually anathema to her
entire program which is help people who
are doing worse than you but now she's
saying don't help people who are doing
your worse than you because they're
doing worse than you
so why would you want to call attention
to that why would you want to call
attention to the struggle
exactly right i mean the rich are fine
with inflation i mean chanel handbags
just went up 60 percent and they're
increasing in sales it's like like the
the sort of the next level uh luxury
good you know and it's so it's fine for
the richer fine inflation creams the
poor in the middle class it's a disaster
and and and uh
really is a theft
of their time and their labor and their
property and people absolutely despise
it it really does represent a transfer
of wealth
from the poor and the middle class from
the
the
the very poor all the way up to the
high bourgeoisie up to the most elite
sectors of society in the administrative
state and they're very very well to do
who don't feel inflation at all that's
what inflation represents
and that's why people despise it very
good yeah and that and we just saw in
kovid so much of that so much of a
wealth transfer right so much of the
depletion of the wages of the working
class and the increase in the um you
know books of the incredibly wealthy and
now the administration is just
continuing that trend and we're now
supposed to look the other way now we're
not supposed to care that poor people
are having a tough time you know
groceries in new york city obviously and
everywhere are skyrocketing we see this
all the time i personally just buy way
way less stuff that my kid wants you
know i'm just like nope we're not
getting that we're not getting that uh
over you know and after that we're gonna
do intermittent
fasting right well look
yeah in for the to uphold the religion
of the bible administration not for any
reasonable uh moral standards
the other thing is that if you notice
what she's saying she's saying shut up
she's got no answer she
she's not even concerned with okay how
do we solve this
this is a thing that must be solved how
do we solve it
um that's not on the menu and and
frankly it it's it's really telling
because it's never been on the menu for
the left how do we solve this
um this wealth
issue or how do we solve this cost of
living issue is never what they care
about what they the only thing they care
about are disparities
and um and and sort of managing
managing those disparities whether it be
turning up the heat in terms of um
in terms of the you know the the getting
the poor to hate the rich or um in terms
like this where she's just trying to say
just shut up and and and lay low because
this economy is being transformed and
you know as as you guys have have have
said uh
it's all about you know it's it's uh
the war on the middle class is something
that goes back
um on the left to the very very
beginning and um
it's it's every everything that that
the um everything that that biden has
done and of course with covet is just
exacerbating that wealth transfer from
the middle classes up until the uh you
know the the
chanel handbag class